[Music]
creature is a movie that you probably
have never even heard of and for good
reason somehow this movie opened in
about 1,500 or so theaters this weekend
that's right
just boom in theaters I mean I saw a
couple random little previews on Apple
trailers because apparently that's the
only people just cut this company paid
to market their film and and I'm looking
on Fandango and it's like creature
coming September 9th to your theater I
was like are you kidding me
I look around it had the same release
that the debt had this movie got put
into theaters today somehow I don't know
how creature is about a group of kids
who are driving on a road we don't know
why suddenly they arrive at this town
this hick town and they decide to go and
look at this local legend apparently
there's this shack where this creature
was there that apparently was at one
point in time a guy who lost his love
and turned into an alligator creature
and now lives in the swamp and just
searches her people sounds like it could
be a fun stupid dumb horror movie right
guess what it's all of that except fun I
hate this movie I literally cannot just
wait to talk to you about this and and I
just I I you have to know about this you
have to know about this movie and and
but don't see it like thinking boy I
want to watch that movie no because he
hates it so much but I had after watch
it because they hate does so much have
to watch it now no this movie is awful I
mean I've seen like probably 80 movies
this year so far this is the worst one I
have seen it's worse than the Smurfs
I thought the Smurfs and Spy Kids four
were bad I thought Conan was bad holy
crap
this movie is awful it's just it's I
can't even make anyone express how bad
this movie is now when I reviewed this
first I got a few comments like calm
down it's just a movie I understand I
understand so this is a rant this is
meant to make you laugh because this is
my unbridled pure emotional hatred for
this movie coming out right now so enjoy
it like I am so mad about this movie
right now that my face is starting to
itch because I'm getting really hot and
tingly like okay let me try to express
this in layman's terms let me try to
express this easily this movie has some
of the worst acting I've seen all year
but you know what that's not really
that's not really a problem because this
is a horror movie you know it's a random
horror movie made by a first-time
director and writer somehow released
wide when it should be on this sci-fi
channel as a sci-fi channel original
movie on Sunday or something but here's
the here's there are more problems in
the movie that I can sum up and quick
there's more problems in the movie than
I get someone quickly the story of this
film yeah this is probably the biggest
part of the story of the movie probably
the biggest probably than just the worst
pop the script of this movie is probably
the worst thing about it this story what
is going on
I can't even fully express the things
that happen in this movie without
seeming like an absolute insane idiot
for watching it and with I mean there
are sweet let me sum it up for you and
you know what I'm your spoil things but
because I don't care no one on the face
of this planet should see this movie
there is of course the creature things
that are necessary for a horror film
random gratuitous sexual things that are
absolutely just thrown in your face
which is in a lot of horror movies but
in this movie it is so obvious that
everyone involved with it knows that it
is a piece of crap
and so like we better put some sexy on
the screen right now because and you
might think well maybe that at least
passed the time guess what it just makes
me it just made me so mad I'm like
look can you please try to make a good
movie can you try to do something you're
giving a chance to let people see you as
a director or an a writer on the big
screen do something just do the studio
whatever the studios of all this movies
do something besides whatever they were
doing in sexual relationships with the
main characters in the band that makes
absolutely no sense families that for
some reason feel human sacrifice is
necessary for this creature the families
are somehow involved with the people in
the man the people on the van that goes
from needing to sacrifice this one girl
she just sacrificing Blee different girl
the creature freakin falls in a hole
that is just created out of nowhere
sucks
dies drowns then all of a sudden comes
out grabs the girl brings the girl back
and the guy screaming falls in the hole
after her we cut to the morning okay the
morning after being in a hole filled
with muddy water all night and we see
the hero just go like oh and I come out
of the hole
yeah it's like killed him here's this
jaw and then they hit the girls fine
big spoilers I don't give a crap this
movie is horrible no one watched this
movie ever
I mean it's so so so bad everything
about this movie is awful I can't even
express it as a normal professional
review anymore I can't even be a
professional film critic right now in
any way because this movie ticked me off
so much is such a bad movie it is so
horrible I don't even want to put the
trailer in this review I'm not even
gonna put the freakin trailer in this
review I don't want you to see should I
actually put the trailer I don't know I
kind of feel like uploading this review
completely uncut I mean it's just mm
maybe I will look don't see creature
creature is honestly one of the worst
movies I've ever seen in my life it's
the worst film of the Year by far I mean
the Smurfs made me so mad because it was
just such a stupid children's movie that
was so disrespectful
and makes them look like idiots and
somehow it's making a crapload of money
which is horrible
but this movie is literally a disgrace
to cinema it is absolutely 100% a
disgrace to anyone who wants to make a
movie anyone who's a film fan anyone who
likes movies and especially anyone who
has a desire to actually make art on
screen anyone who has a desire to do
that will watch this movie and think
holy crap why is this happening and it
just ticks me off because there are
plenty of people out there who could
make a great movie and who want to make
a great movie instead opportunities like
this are given to people who literally
take their poop and stuff it in a
computer drive and hope that somehow
some things gonna shoot out that's a
good movie I mean don't ever see this
wow I think I'm gonna upload cut so they
upload it and cut I think I should I'm
going to I'm gonna you creature an F a
big old fat F my lowest grade it's a
club unto su 0 0 stars just like just
like the Smurfs except it's worse than
the Smurfs literally everything about
this movie is horrible everything I mean
the only thing about this movie that I
thought okay was was the one guy in the
movie who seemed like he wasn't an idiot
and I was like hey this guy doesn't seem
like he's as dumb as the rest of them I
mean that's like saying that that's like
saying that a dog pooped over there and
it might end up fertilizing the grass at
some time yeah but the poop still there
so obviously that's gonna look
disgusting right I mean maybe in the end
it'll it'll help a little bit but I mean
it really is just a big pile of poop
just like creature that was a dumb
illustration but I'm basically saying
this movie was like a giant pile of crap
please never see it ever III I just
totally stuttered because of this movie
uh yeah this movie is literally poo
plastic never ever sea creature horrible
horrible horrible horrible movie one of
the worst movies I've ever seen in my
life in fact I mean in some ways it's
worse than Dragonball Evolution four
shirts there's just a
movie raped my childhood so I hate it
more but seriously I know you're
probably thinking boy man I'm tempted to
watch this movie right now just because
of how bad he says it is but no no
seriously never watch this movie you
will be upset at life like halfway
through okay like okay like the reason I
got to see it early was I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna say this it's online I
watch it online I didn't go to the
theater even though it's playing in
theaters today I watched it online thank
God literally thank God for not having
seen this in the theaters but fury the
film fans like dude let's watch this
movie together I still we start watching
it and I turned off Skype and later I
text him and he's like dude I didn't
even finish it he couldn't finish it
fury of the film fan could not finish
this movie I finished it purely because
I wanted to do this video and tell you
how god-awful this movie if I mean it
literally is the F for the creature fur
creature it's not called duck creature
so yeah these are my uncut this is our
code review what do you know no jump
cuts another totally improv
100% improv no no it's nothing pure
emotional outrage on this film I hope
you enjoyed this review tell your
friends not to see that movie ever
holy crap
[Music]